quoi que
ces messieurs dames
si l'idée d'un toit ouais ça m'est venu
comme ça il ya chaque fois j'ai
téléphoné à tous les copains presque
tous m'ont dit tu me retire une épine du
pied parce que je sais pas quoi faire
toi même et individuellement tu dis je
vais envoyer un petit chèque tu faire
quoi je me suis dit sion se fédèrent
alors là on va pouvoir on n'a plus une
puissance atomique sur 760 neige pas
tous les comics d'envoyer
individuellement un petit chèque bien
sûr de dire millions mais surtout pas
commis que j'ai envoyée et surtout est
ce que je rajoutais une petite chose
c'est peut-être l'an zéro parce que
c'est un élan de générosité que si
jamais vu sur la planète je vais
maintenant c'est peut-être le zéro tu
cèdes du nord qui vient au secours des
suds mais tu sais on est quand même gros
grosso merdo or le tsunami jusqu'à
l'afrique un tsunami par mois 1
si dieu là sais c'est que c'est la
nature qui a tué une partie de
l'humanité l'humanité s'est rabiboché
pour venir au secours
or en ayant un élan de générosité encore
une fois jamais vu alors que kc 10
hommes qui tu disais on s'en branle un
au rwanda cinq cent mille morts à la
machette 500 milles de famine et de
maladie un million de morts un sixième
du génocide juif en six mois
tout le monde s'en branle il ya aucune
mobilisation là
non il faut aujourd'hui
bien l'énorme le vent de solidarité il
faut il faut gonfler les voiles à tout
le monde c'est le moment ou jamais c'est
peut-être là 02 du nord qui s'occupe du
sujet qui a une mondialisation du
malheur et une mondialisation de
l'entraidé que c'est assez c'est assez
génial ce qui s'est passé là un
jean-marie bon on va pas parler de votre
prochaine tournée
on va pas parler des dessins de votre
femme mia patch celles annoncées pour
les ions qu'on les voit dans les femmes
essayent de lancer gilles rioux menée
avec un t-shirt avec un nichon là et
bien là et de marquer mi6 bigard c'est
pour dire c'est une nouvelle mode lance
les niches en décalé ça c'est plus les
nichoirs la même hauteur comme en commun
bac
comment ça va elle va bien elle va bien
on rigole elle est vivante et bien là
pas récupérer tout son sens comme elle
elle est vivante c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on veut juste jeu charbonneau et deux
trous du cul qui l'ont sacré mais non
oui j'ai l'âge fadoq
ghazi regard des qualités
cd
france dans le vol grâce à des led pour
15 euros
tigo